a lot of times when a man is ready for a
wife the next woman that comes along
that meets the criteria that he's
looking for he will get married it's it
may not even dependent on cuz she's so
special it's just that she's meeting
certain criteria that he can work with
and when a man is ready men own marriage
they own relationship we own sex so if a
man wants marriage he is tired of the
streets he wants a wife and his mind is
set on that the next girl that comes
along that offers at least a large
portion at least the majority of the
things that he's looking for he will
settle down and that's why women will
say why is he with her she's not even
that fine she's not that bad his
ex-girlfriend looked better and we will
start talking about the looks